[Applause]
well thank you very much everybody
please sit down very important day and
we're gathered this morning at the White
House to honor our solemn duty to
America's best bravest and finest who I
know so well in a few moments I will
sign a bar bipartisan bill to fully
reauthorize the nine elective 11 Victims
Compensation Fund so the 9/11 Victims
Compensation Fund is something you've
all worked on very hard and the day has
come today we come together as one
nation to support our September 11th
Heroes to care for their families and to
renew our eternal vow never ever forget
before I go further this morning we
express our deepest sadness and sorrow
for the families who lost a precious
loved one in the horrific shooting last
night in Gilroy California while
families were spending time together at
a local festival a wicked murderer
opened fire and killed three innocent
citizens including a young child we
grieve for their families that we ask
that God will comfort them with his
overflowing mercy and grace we're
praying for those who are recovering
right now in the hospital some very very
serious injuries
we thank the brave members of law
enforcement they never let us down who
swiftly killed the shooter we reaffirm
our national will to answer violence
with the courage determination or
resolve of one American family we will
continue to work together as communities
and as citizens to stop evil prevent
violence and protect the safety of all
Americans we're joined for today's
ceremony by our wonderful vice president
Mike Pence thank you Mike very much
thank you along with many distinguished
guests I want to begin by recognizing a
leader many of you know very well on
September 11th he declared the city of
New York and the United States of
America is much stronger than any group
of barbaric terrorists our strength and
our willingness to defend ourselves will
ultimately prevail and he was right a
great mayor of the city of New York
our greatest mayor in my opinion now
what do I know
Rudy Giuliani stand up Rudy great job
Rudy
great job Rudy's got a lot of guts
thanks also to Deputy Attorney General
Jeffrey Rosen for being here thank you
Jeff thank you very much along with
senator Deb Fischer and Representatives
Michael Burgess Chris Collins Brian
Fitzpatrick Peter King John Joyce Marc
meadows and Dan Musick please stand up
fellas thank you thank you Peter in the
wake of the September 11th attacks
courageous Americans raced into smoke
fire and debris in lower Manhattan the
Pentagon and a field in Shanksville
Pennsylvania the whole world witness the
might and resilience of our nation in
the extraordinary men and women of the
New York Fire Department and the New
York Police Department selfless Patriots
of unmatched character and devotion I
grew up with them so I can tell you
that's absolutely true it's always nice
to really know your subject I know that
subject these are great people we also
commemorate the heroes of the Port
Authority police and I want to thank you
all for being here tremendous people the
first responders from across the country
rushed to New York and worked endless
days and sleepless nights they fought to
rescue every person trapped in the
and then search for months to find the
remains of the fallen the love and
loyalty of our 911 responders knew no
bounds today we are deeply honored to be
in the presence of more than 60 of these
exceptional heroes they answered
Tara with the emotional strength of true
American Warriors what every 911
responder please stand up please
all you first responders Wow wait thank
you thank you fellas
great looking group of people you
great-looking group of people thank you
very much you inspire all of humanity
and you know that we're all so greatly
moved to have with us families of our
fallen heroes our nation owes each of
you a profound debt that no words or
deeds will ever repay but we can and we
will keep our nation's promise to you in
a few moments I will sign the 9/11
Victims Compensation front this law
makes permanent the financial support
for families who lost precious loved
ones as a result of September 11th
attacks it also provides pensions for
those who are suffering from cancer and
other illnesses stemming from the toxic
debris they were exposed to in the
aftermath of the attacks many of those
affected were firefighters police
officers and other first responders and
I was down there also but I'm not
considering myself a first responder but
I was down there I spent a lot of time
down there with you since September 11th
we have lost more than 2,000 first
responders and survivors to 911 related
cancers and illnesses currently
thousands of men and women are battling
cancer and other illnesses due to 9/11
we pledged to stand by the families of
those affected today and every day we
will stand with you I want to thank
lawmakers in both parties for working
with common purpose to pass this vital
and critical legislation
here with us for this signing ceremony
are the three families whose loved ones
are memorialized in the title of this
bill New York Police Department
detective James Zadroga spent more than
450 hours serving at Ground Zero in 2006
James died from a lung disease to his
father Joseph and his daughter Tyler Ann
who join us
detectives ed rogas heroism will uplift
our nation forever
won't be forgotten we will always
remember what he did for us please stand
up please
[Applause]
also present today is the family of East
Meadow volunteer firefighter ray
Pfeiffer I know East Meadow very well
great place great people for eight
months ray worked constantly at Ground
Zero in 2017 at the age of 59 he died
from cancer here with us today is Ray's
wife Karen his daughter Taylor and his
son Terence now a New York City
firefighter please stand up thank you
and I know ray must be watching over you
looking down right now from heaven on
this beautiful rose garden very very
proud of you thank you thank you very
much
the third namesake of the bill is New
York City detective Luis Alvarez last
month his powerful testimony in Congress
touched the heart of our nation a few
days later he passed from this life into
eternity we are privileged to have with
us detective Alvarez his brother Phillip
and his wife Aileen and his sons Tyler
and Ben please stand please please thank
you thank you
thank you very much thank you very much
I want each of you to know that America
is holding you in the arms of its
wonderful wonderful heart and we're all
grieving by your side our whole nation
prays and pays tribute to the incredible
life and legacy of detective Alvarez how
hard he worked and how much he suffered
and we really want to thank him he was
really something people understood it
very well it's really great thank you we
have an obligation and it's a sacred
obligation to the families and first
responders of 9/11 here with us today is
Chief John Joyce former fire chief of
the midtown Manhattan firehouse when
September 11th 15 of his men raced into
the ashes of hell and gave their lives
to this day chief joy still mentors many
of their 28 children chief Joyce spent
seven months working at Ground Zero in
2011 he was diagnosed with cancer
he has also endured other severe 9/11
related illnesses but the chief is a
fighter he is definitely a fighter as he
says because of this bill he does not
have to fear for the families of his
firehouse whose loved ones made the
ultimate sacrifice
chief Joyce you have our everlasting
gratitude please chief thank you
thank you - thank you for being and say
hello to everybody yeah - every 911 hero
you poured out your heart your sweat
your soul and everything you had for
your country you ran toward the wreckage
into a ball of flames like frankly
nobody in this country had ever seen you
searched for survivors you went back day
after day and night after night to save
lives and return the Fallen to their
families to rebuild and recover and to
show the entire world that nothing will
ever break America's spirit over the
last two decades you have endured
hardship with amazing grace
an incredible grit through it all you
care and you work and you love and you
will always remember all of those great
families you lift up our communities and
you remind us all what it means to stand
united as one nation under God for your
entire lives you have gone far beyond
your duty to us and today we strive to
fulfill our sacred duty to you we love
you we honor you and we thank you god
bless you all thank you
[Applause]
now I'm going to sign this bill into law
and I don't know if this stage will hold
it but if it doesn't we're not falling
very far but I'd like to ask the
families and I'd also like to ask the
first responders to come up and we'll
we'll give we'll give this stage a shot
let's see how well built made in America
let's see how well built it is okay come
on up
oh yeah
[Applause]